I see no obstacle to computers
eventually becoming conscious in some
sense that'll be a fascinating
experience on as a physicist I want to
know if those computers do physics the
same way humans do physics and there's
no doubt that those machines will be
able to evolve computationally
potentially to faster rate than humans
and in the long term the the ultimate
highest forms of consciousness on the
planet may not be purely biological but
that's not necessarily a bad thing we
always present computers as if they
don't have capabilities of empathy or
emotion but I would think that any
intelligent machine would ultimately
have experience that it's a learning
machine and ultimately it would learn
from its experience like like a
biological conscious being and therefore
it's hard for me to believe that it
would not be able to have many of the
characteristics that we now associate
with being human
Elon Musk and others who are expressed
concern is Stephen Hawking our friends
of mine and I understand their potential
concerns but I'm frankly not as
concerned about AI in the near term
it'll very least as many many of my
friends and colleagues are it's far less
powerful than people imagine I mean if
you try to get a robot to fold laundry
and I've just been told you can't even
get full robots to fold laundry if
someone just wrote me they were
surprised when I said an elevator is an
old example of the fact that when you
get an elevator you're it's a primitive
form of a computer and you're and you're
giving up the control of the fact that
it's gonna take you where you want to go
cars are the same thing machines are
useful because they're tools that help
us do what we want to do and I think
computational machines are exempt are
good examples of that one has to be very
careful in creating machines to not
assume they're more capable than they
are that's true in cars that's true in
vehicles that we make that's true and
weapons we create that's true in
defensive mechanisms we create and so to
me the dangers of AI would are mostly
due to the
that people may assume the devices they
create are more capable than they are
and don't need more control and
monitoring I guess I find the
opportunities to be far more exciting
than the dangers the unknown is always
dangerous but ultimately machines and
computational machines are improving our
lives in many ways we of course have to
realize that the rate at which machines
are evolving in capability may far
exceed the rate at which society is able
to deal with them the fact that of
teenagers aren't talking to each other
all but always looking at their phones
not just teenagers I was just in a
restaurant here in New York the this
afternoon and half the people we're not
talking to people they were with but
we're staring at their phones well that
may be not a good thing for it's a
silent er action and people may have to
come to terms with that but I don't
think people view their phones as a
danger they view their phones as a tool
that in many ways allow them to do what
they would otherwise do more effectively